hey how's it going everyone in this
javascript tutorial I'm going to go over
the string operator in JavaScript we'll
walk through it and explain it in detail
like how it can be used we'll go over
the most commonly used operations on
strings like we'll cover had to declare
them in multiple ways how to concatenate
them together basic string manipulation
and finally how to combine data into a
string in JavaScript so if you have
something like my dog's name is blank
and she's blank years old how do you
insert other variables into that string
we'll cover that in detail so by the end
of it you should be able to do that with
ease to begin let's start up the Python
server so let's just go here and let's
get dev tools going I cover this
environment set up in my first video I
encourage you to go back and watch it if
you want to be able to reproduce what I
do here exactly now if you remember back
to my video on data types in JavaScript
I covered some basic string declarations
let's do a quick refresher this is how
you declare a string and you can also
declare it with single quotes those are
two common ways let's just go over a
couple more quickly just so that you're
aware of their existence let's say you
have a number and another data type and
you want to make that into a string the
way you do that is go here let this one
equal new string 3.14159 and you see the
3.14159 that could be any number or any
other data types it can be converted to
a string a lot of the most common data
types and JavaScript have implicit
string conversions and so you can do
something like this with numbers or any
of the other data types that we covered
so far and it should it should show up
just fine
now let's say you want to write a really
really long string one that spans
several sentences in the editor if you
did that it'll just get all crammed into
a single line but maybe you wanted to
show up nicely and readable so let's say
that we have a really long string but
long string now previously you might
have to do it something like this now
you can see that this isn't really
readable so what we can do is we can go
here and you can insert a slash and then
go on to the next line now if we run
this you can see that this shows up just
fine in the console there's actually a
second way of declaring a really really
long string and I'll show you now so
instead of the slash what you do is you
take away the you end the quote and just
put a plus now you can use indenting
because when you use the slash before
you weren't allowed to indent or do
anything like that but here you can
indent so we go here and it works just
fine which kind of leads us to the next
thing we use pluses here so we go here
and we've got the plus symbol here and
that is the JavaScript string operator
for adding two strings together what
this does is it concatenates two strings
together forming a new one that's the
union of those two to make that clear
let's run through another example just
get rid of all of this stuff but that's
one equal
to eat but fast here we go it's uh three
equals two
I always print that out we should see a
full sentence I love to eat pizza the
point here is that s three now contains
the union of s1 and s2 which is I love
to heat and pizza that's because the
concatenation operator the plus sign
root here it creates a new string which
is the result of the second string being
appended to the first string one thing
that you may also notice is that spaces
count so you got a space right here you
can't neglect them you can't leave them
out because if we go back and we remove
this space for example we save that and
we run you'll notice that eat pizza is
you'll notice that eat and pizza are
kind of smushed together as one word the
point here the takeaway is that spaces
count so just make a note of that and be
careful when you're putting things
together now it's not just other strings
that you can use the Plus on its any
data type that could be implicitly
converted into a string most of the
common JavaScript ones have a conversion
of some kind so doing something like
let's say s4
ten it says pizza now ten isn't a string
but it gets converted into a string when
you use it with other string so you use
it with the plus operator and other
strings and it gets converted into a
string now somewhat interesting side
effect of this is this you can go here
now you might be able to guess what's
gonna happen here but let's just run it
and see so print it out ten which is
expected but is 10 a number or is it a
string it's been converted into a string
now we can declare strings and put
together some increasingly complicated
ones using variables and that's great
but often we need to modify them as the
program runs so say we've got text input
on the page that lets you enter your
name you're you're writing a web page
that has an input and users login and
they write their name and then we write
hey name how's it going so they type in
their name and you types like something
like hey name the weather weather today
is minus 11 what we need to be able to
do is some basic string manipulation
now string instances in JavaScript have
a whole bunch of methods available
methods being functions that can be
invoked given an instance of an object
so it's not just a function by itself
like console dialog but it requires you
to say have a string already in which
case you can use these so called
instance methods a lot of these require
much more in-depth tutorials we're not
going to touch on a lot of them
but I put together a list of the most
common ones that should give you a
really solid base so let's just get rid
of everything here so that we can focus
on them and we'll start with an example
so let s let's call it string G 1 equal
apples and oranges the first method
we're gonna look at is includes and what
that does is it checks whether or not
the string that you have like string 1
apples and oranges are terrible blah
blah blah whether or not it includes a
smaller string that you specify so here
let's run through some examples log we
run this just call this s so of the
sentence here does include the word
orange but it doesn't include the word
mango includes goes and looks inside the
sentence and it checks whether or not
the substring that you specify is
included in the sentence or the text now
we're gonna go look at starts with and
ends with
you can probably guess what these do
they're gonna check whether or not the
string starts with or ends with a
specific substring that you specify so
here we go okay remember that the
substring doesn't have to be a full word
it can be it can be a sentence a smaller
sentence on its own it can be just part
of a word it's just some string that
you're looking for now we go and run
this and you can see that the string
both started with the word Apple and
ends with hate them now one interesting
thing to note here is that these are
case sensitive so watch this reload and
you can see this fails because in the
original sentence a was capitalized but
we looked for a lowercase Apple now the
next method we're going to look for is
replaced and what this does is it it
goes through your string and it looks
for a specific substring that you
specify and then it replaces it with
another one that you specify so let's
take an example here we're gonna go for
oranges and we're gonna replace that
with pears go hit reload apples and
pears are terrible and I hate them and
just like the other and just like and
just like the previous examples these
are case sensitive as well the next on
the list is trimmed
and what this does is it trims
whitespace from both the beginning and
the end of the string now whitespace if
you haven't if you haven't heard of that
is the name given to text like spaces
tabs that kind of thing a use case for
this is imagine again we brought a web
page that we're making and you've got a
text input on the page and users type
their names in and you write out hello
person so they type in their name so
they've got a field here and they type
in their name and then you write hello
person person now the problem here is
that although most people will write
everything properly a few people will
maybe accidentally hit the space bar at
the beginning or at the end and what you
want to do is just clean this up so that
you don't have a whole bunch of random
spaces in your sentence and the way you
do that is that you just go and take the
result and you run trim before you
display it so let's do an example here
so let name equal whoops I did a whole
bunch of spaces more spaces so we write
this out you will end up with is a bunch
of junk here but here we do this and
there we go hello Bob and the last thing
that I want to cover is the to uppercase
and to lowercase functions
again these are pretty easy to predict
what they do let's just run through an
example here a little dog and that was
pretty much what we expected it all
uppercase same thing we do lowercase the
interesting thing about to uppercase and
to lowercase is that there's some neat
tricks that you can do so just as an
example let's say that you want to check
if that original sentence the one that
says apples and oranges are terrible
let's check if it has the word Apple in
it but let's make that check
case-insensitive
meaning it doesn't matter whether or not
individual characters are capitalized in
lowercase we'll find it no matter what
so you remember s dot say you remember s
dot includes Apple fails but
if you convert it to lowercase if you
convert it to lowercase first it
succeeds so when you need to search for
something like Apple you can write it in
lowercase one time and not have to worry
about whether or not it was uppercase or
lowercase or alternating or who knows
how it was written in a sentence and
there we go
given what we've covered today you
should have a basic grasp of how to
manipulate strings in JavaScript which
is really important depending on the
type of work you do often front-end
people have to do quite a bit of this if
you have any questions or concerns let
me know in the comments and that about
wraps up this video in the series I hope
you enjoyed it and I'll see you soon
Cheers